joining me here part of the Fox coverage
of the 2019 FIFA Women's World Cup is
somebody who's won two of them
participated in five of them in Finals
appearances a former captain of the u.s.
women's national soccer team
welcome to the Rich Eisen show Christy
Pierce Rampone how are you good how are
you I'm great what is it like to step on
the field representing this country in
such an event like this what does it
feel like pretty amazing you know it's
the journey to get there and then once
you make that final roster and you're on
that stage it's a big stage you know
there's a lot of pressure all the
countries are there competing for the
same thing of winning that World Cup
it's unbelievable but you have to get
game by game that's I think the biggest
picture of making sure you don't look
too far ahead sure and that's a part of
the process of winning a World Cup by
just looking around first match right
national anthem playing I cannot imagine
what feeling must of course through your
veins you get the chills you know you're
playing for your country you know you
think about all those all the prep work
leading into it and you kind of just
listen to that national anthem digest it
and then when that whistle blows it's
game on mm-hmm so now let's talk about
the prospects for the Women's National
Team this time around ranked first
obviously in FIFA rankings but a totally
different team even though they are I
guess technically longer in the tooth
than most of them out there average age
of 28 I just set this table to send
things off to you what'd you think of
the chances for the team this year
I think their chances are are very good
you know we're coming into this World
Cup ready and prepared
I think we'll be peaking at the right
time we're very deep in the attacking
side of the game I think we are little
lacking in depth in the defensive side
as a unit but I think overall you're
going to see the u.s. scoring a lot of
goals in this World Cup very different
than 2015 which was a solid defensive
unit less goals being scored but I think
with our attack with Alex Morgan Megan
Rapinoe Tobin Heath their chemistry up
top is going to be something special to
watch well obviously leadership of
people like yourself Abby Wambach not
there who does fill that void we're
gonna see you know Megan Rapinoe and
Alex Morgan I think stepping up in those
difficult moments because in the game of
soccer 90 minutes there are moments
where you're gonna lapse
and you just matters how you gonna get
out of it you know and I think the
players will look to those two to really
help them get through it as well as
Carli Lloyd coming on Pilate in games
well the the tournament starts with the
host French team taking on the korea
republic that'll be on friday tomorrow
3:00 Eastern on FS 1 first match for the
United States women's national team is
against Thailand live on Fox at 3:00 in
the afternoon Eastern Time on Tuesdays
and is that a good thing that it takes
that it's that the first match is later
in the first round or I think you know
they get to kind of see the game in the
tournament you know from watching it
from afar getting used to being in
France the environment the distractions
and I think you know playing against
Thailand which is a lesser opponent so
they should be able to start getting the
nerves out right you know especially
with a lot of younger players on the
team in the midfield so I think it'll be
good for them to go from Thailand and
then to Chile and then Sweden who will
be there their best opponent in the
group stage well we know about Sweden
all right now obviously this is the the
side that knocked Team USA out of the
Rio Olympics in 2016 we all know what
choice words Hope Solo had back then
what what do you think is there is this
a rivalry game do you think playing
Sweden a lot in group stage right
definitely thinking it's the first time
since right I think it's a rival you
know our old coach ps2 hog who was from
Sweden knows it very well and I think in
the Olympics you know there was a lot of
mind games per se Oh thinking that in
that game she's no longer the coach but
Sweden definitely always comes after to
beat the u.s. you know I think they've
heard about the u.s. for so long that I
mean think everybody's gone in for the
u.s. let's be honest but Sweden has
something I think extra in their
motivation to beat the US by hearing
about us all the time so that will be a
difficult game but it's group stage you
know the top two teams advance in each
group so you'll see the u.s. move on and
that would be a determining factor of
who they'll meet in the round of 16 and
then I got to the quarter so who's the
one in the round of the stick around a
16 that lurks right now if you look over
the steering wheel right I think you
know coming up against a Spain or Canada
or Netherlands teams that we could meet
in the round of 16 all very technical
teams
Spain is very organized tough to break
down defensively they have a great
attack so it's it's gonna be each game
is gonna be a kind of a different game
plan I'm heading into from the round of
16 on two-time World Cup champion
three-time Olympic gold medalist with
Fox Sports for this world cup Christy
Pierce Rampone here on the Rich Eisen
show what give me the name of somebody
young player from Team USA that we might
be talking about a little bit more one
week from today two weeks from today I
think in the midfield you're gonna see
Lindsey her R and Andros Lavelle and
their first World Cups you know breaking
barriers I think you're gonna see them
have exceptional games their experience
and the fact they've they've played in
high-level games but they just haven't
been in a World Cup so I would see them
be breakout players in this World Cup
and what would you say if you were on
this squad - the younger players what
advice would you give just relax
you know enjoy the moment you know take
it minute by minute and don't look past
each game because they the goal is to
win the World Cup and I think if you get
too anxious and to stress about getting
to that final you lose your momentum
throughout the game so it's just you
know limit the distractions focus on the
team in the locker room keep the locker
room going going well and confident and
just take a game by game when you say
distractions you mean like hanging in
France for a weekend or for a month I
mean distractions of like social media
media as well as like family and friends
that's why the hardest thing is making
time for those people are coming over to
support you but also realize that you
have to like it's just your legs it's
like you can enjoy France later there's
no I would imagine downtime here a
little downtime you know because you're
prepping you know once you finish that
game you're prepping on to the next game
and you know resting traveling
recovering and preparing for the next
opponent alright let's let's stop be so
nationalistic for a quick second here
else elsewhere outside of these United
States
give me a group of these they're a group
of death the so called group of death in
this in this draw I don't think there is
a group of death death I think there's
you pretty much can look across the
board and see the top
you coming out of each group it'll be
that third there's four third-place
teams that will advance but you always
you know you have to look at Germany
France England is making a run a young
Australian that's doing very well it
doesn't matter who you meet up with and
you know where the US will fall into
place
reaching the des quarters and on now you
were here watching in our green room in
the at the end of the last hour
thirsty fierce Rampone here on the Rich
Eisen show and you watched the three of
us draw I did our adopted nation states
yes out of our deadwood hat you have
named two of the sides that we we
plucked out a hat unfortunately Mike
Dell to five yet to hear Christie talk
about Nigeria very much sorry Mike so if
you don't mind would you could make a
run okay I will say they're very
athletic they're fast okay unlike Mike
so far and they give up yeah very
athletic see you know younger team come
into their own younger team though my
god a group stage you see you're saying
there's a chance there's a chance
there's a possibility okay what about
England
England's gonna do well they've got an
amazing coach and Phil Neville he's you
know played at the highest level he's
got these girls confident ready so you
got a good one okay four good things now
you already talked about Spain having
very fun to watch yes okay but but Team
USA is standing in the way
yeah Team USA is in the way I just
wasn't going to choose Team USA out of
the Hat
and I hopefully wasn't gonna just choose
somebody just look at me gonna
unfortunately that'll be a quick one I
just didn't want somebody that was gonna
be right in the way of Team USA out of
there I mean Spain possibly in the round
of 16
oh my gosh you never know I know the
actor Timothy Olyphant chose Canada he
chose wisely huh Canada's very good Dave
okay been coming along they have
Sinclair who has like four goals away
from beating Abby Wambach's record she's
someone I played against for many years
a very good leader so they have a good
leadership on on Canada who's the best
competitor you ever played with with
Abby hands down you know it's stutter
huh yeah no Abby just what was that
little just because she has this
mentality that no one else brings to the
game like she loves the pressure she's
able to finish and be composed in the
box and that is a sign of a good athlete
especially good forward that just is
mindful of others but she's just the
triple threat she's you know she's so
good in the air she's a great leader she
can finish you know their feet or her
head she's just someone you want on your
team one of those players teammates that
you didn't want to let down with your
own play and thus needed to raise your
own so and it was it was so much fun
playing with obviously being in the back
being able to scream up to her on the
floor line as well as her screaming back
to me like we have such a connection on
the field and knew just signs you know
because you can't really hear herself
talking in a real cup it's so loud so
you have to just be aware of body
language and that's what she brought
like she just brought so much energy and
the energy is contagious you know
especially in moments when people are
fearful of the unknown of making
mistakes Abby's right there to secure
them well leaders don't just stop
leading once they stopped playing and
she has been leading the charge if you
will alongside with the women's national
team that sued the US Soccer Federation
for equal pay and the Women's National
Team has generated more money and had
more success than their male
counterparts for Team USA why do you
think there's a disparity in pay do you
think Christi you think it's just the
lack of resources and the awareness to
you know put forward for the women's
team you know we've been very successful
we just haven't really gotten the
support from US soccer they're there
they've been very helpful but now it's
it's time for them to just recognize the
success
of the team and respect that and I don't
want don't I think it was just more so
on the fact that they don't I don't we
were winning so that kind of pushes
aside I think the expectation was always
to win to be top three and we always
were there so I guess they just felt
like they didn't really have to focus on
us and now it's time that we have been
successful the numbers are there the
ticket sales have been proven now they
just have to put a little bit more time
into promoting the team back in 99 we
pretty much promoted ourselves and look
what the final was it was like 90,000
and that was all on just the commitment
of the players of doing radio doing you
know sneak attacks doing clinics doing
camps everything that it could do to
produce like a tournament like that and
who's to say now and 2019 if US Soccer
promotes the theme the girls like they
should the tickets you know people will
come the sponsors will come and you're
already seeing it through this World Cup
how many sponsors are backing this
women's team and now we just need a
little bit extra from your soccer and I
think the women have kind of backed off
from it now and like they need to really
focus on preparing and winning this
World Cup and you know we'll probably
hear about it more after a short you
know we're now now we're playing yeah
the why do you think men the men's side
has not been as successful in the World
Cup as clearly the women have been just
so many different sports in an America
that men are choosing you know between
the you know NFL NBA NHL you know
there's so many other sports out there
and soccer was kind of the back burner
it was like it was last but now I think
education in America for soccer and
seeing it on TV and MLS doing much
better
from the start I think you're starting
to see more people turn to soccer well I
mean we have a couple of teams here in
Los Angeles as well I mean just here in
the alone yeah and I just know having
coached AYSO and having all three of my
kids go through youth soccer as well I
mean they can't get enough of it they do
it's a good starting system I think
we're still behind 12 20 years plus as a
parent they're running around the street
I mean look I love baseball more than
life itself and I
of watching my kids play it but when
they're not swinging a bat they
literally are standing in the field I'd
love that they're running around they're
just it it's great for later in the day
for when they're tired out yes but it's
also great exercise these amazing figure
solving being on a team sport
you know leadership roles there's so
much that comes to you know
accountability within soccer so it's the
great I love it and my daughter my
daughter she's now five I'll tell you
this story
christy is different she was like three
my wife got her in a soccer clinic with
a whole bunch of other kids were like
twenty five kids out there and the
person running the clinic I think it was
at the end of his rope a little bit when
he got 25 the ones out there and he
starts screaming find space everybody
Speight you because everyone's right
around the bulbs it's behind space so my
daughter at age three looks at the
little boy next to her and just shoved
him over and I'm like yes she's
definitely ready to watch the Women's
World Cup on Fox fs1 and fs2 with you I
look forward to the to the coverage
thanks for coming on here of course
thanks I got at Christy Pierce Rampone I
think she gives you the the leg up there
Chris with England let's go then I got
Spain if I can somehow avoid Team USA
and then Nigeria good luck to you sir
we're good four more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app